wie sieht es ein jahr nach beginn der
korona krise in pflegeheimen aus das
altenheim in bergneustadt bei
gummersbach gestattet uns einen seltenen
einblick
zuvor hat sich das gesamte drehteam
testen lassen ist alles weg andrea gab
läuft von zimmer zu zimmer und räumt
gestört die altenpflegerin kümmert sich
gemeinsam mit fünf kolleginnen um 36
menschen schon vor corinna war das
personal knapp
und jetzt fallen auch noch helfer und
ehrenamtliche aus wenn dann auch noch
kollegen in karachi müssen kommt sie der
arbeit nicht mehr hinterher hin und her
hin und her dann ist da jemand da jemand
möchte was man muss immer gucken wie man
allen gerecht wird meistens schafft man
fällt nicht weil wir halt zu wenig
personal haben ja sie sagen so ist
richtig wir möchten mehr personal haben
fast alle bewohnerinnen und bewohner
sind geimpft und die meisten
spielerinnen auf andrea maske tragen
muss er weiterhin körperliche nähe zu
den menschen ist hier richtig und die
korona krise bedeutet für alle im
altenheim eindruck die arbeitsbelastung
ist noch einmal gestiegen
gut so ja bis gleich
und das kann jetzt noch fünf sechs mal
passieren dass sie wieder raus kommt und
dann guckt sie dann sucht sie jemanden
dann möchte sie wieder ins bett gebracht
werden und so ist das halt ganz oft so
ist unser alltag in der pflege menschen
im heim brauchen nicht nur pflegen
sondern vor allem auch zuwendung warten
sie auf das heißt ich setz mich jetzt zu
ihnen noch frau langsam langsam langsam
der ist noch glaube ich ein bisschen zu
heiß oder warten sie bis der kaffee ein
bisschen abgekühlt ist
ich setze mich kurz dahin trinkwasser
mit mir
dann gehe ich mit ihm
zweimal gab es hier infizierte und alle
mussten in quarantäne auf ihre zimmer
anders als in vielen anderen
pflegeheimen ist aber niemand an kur
wird 19 gestorben
doch auch hier ging in der zweiten welle
die angst um als die infektionszahlen im
dezember in die höhe schnellten
dass ich angst hatte dass meine kinder
von der schule was herr bringen und mich
anstecken und dass ich dann halt hier
das weitergebe ohne dass ich das wusste
halt bei den alten menschen verläuft
zwar meistens tödlich
deswegen sind wir auch so sensibel damit
und versuchen alles richtig zu machen
und möchten nicht dass er reinkommt
heimleiter georg huber trägt die
verantwortung für zwei pflegeheime in
der region ausbrüche zu verhindern ist
sein oberstes ziel
dafür muss er auch mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen immer wieder motivieren
durchzuhalten
jeder sieht die todesfälle
jeder nimmt war das risiko indem wir
leben und auch die aufgabe der sozialen
gemeinschaft auch das ist ja ein
riesenproblem für die alten menschen
sie sind hier im haus sie können kaum
noch raus das fehlt unglaublich das
soziale miteinander ist empfindlich
gestört
ich glaube dass die politiker das schon
sehen aber ich glaube dass ihre
entscheidungsebene zu weit weg von der
basis ist wir wissen sie überhaupt was
hier vor ort passiert ich habe zweifel
haben sie sich mal wirklich hilflos und
alleingelassen gefühlt
ja es gab viele situationen wo ich mich
hilflos gefühlt habe vor allem aber
allein gelassen weil letztlich sie
tragen die verantwortung hier muss es
ist sie werden angerufen wenn irgendwas
ist sie müssen sich mal wieder
entscheiden
ich sag mal auch für mich persönlich war
es aus sprungkraft und quarantäne im
heim für alle eine herausforderung
bewohnerinnen und bewohner auf den
einzelnen etagen oder in ihren zimmern
abschotten
fast unwirklich das problem ist daher
es gibt ja auch leute bewohner die nicht
orientiert sind und da ist halt immer
schlecht oder dieses verständlich hin zu
machen dass sie im zimmer bleiben sollen
deswegen manche verstehen es ja nicht
mehr
sie wollen ja auch dann in gesellschaft
seien deswegen kommen sie auch raus
versuchen jemanden wir möchten reden sie
möchten einfach nähe von anderen
bewohnern haben vom personal
hallo da sind wir wieder ja und jetzt
dieses tun was tue ich nicht mit doch
durch möchten sie ins bett dann gehen
wir hier in bergneustadt haben es
pflegekräfte und heimleitung mit viel
engagement geschafft das schlimmste zu
verhindern
aber vielleicht haben sie einfach auch
nur glück gehabt andernorts wurden
pflegeheime für viele zur todesfalle
wir treffen einen pfleger er möchte
anonym bleiben
ein berichtet uns aus einem rein in den
170 schwer demente menschen lebten
mitten in einem corona ausbruch ende
dezember
wurde die impfung im heim gestoppt mit
katastrophalen folgen
[Musik]
wir hatten ausbruch auf einen
wohnbereich und das waren dann zu dem
zeitpunkt bis ende ende dezember neun
oder zehn bewohner die erkrankt waren
mitte januar waren es schon an die 40
und das ging dann einfach ab je weiter
das wurden über 100 weil es ein
ausbruchsgeschehen gab wurde die
einrichtung gestrichen von der liste und
blockiert bis februar wie so viele
menschen sterben angehörige darauf
vorzubereiten dass gestorben wird fast
täglich sind mitarbeiter erkrankt und
wurde nach hause geschickt
das war sehr schlimm da hatten alle
angst haben zu dem ich geh ich hätte
verstehen können wenn wir alles wochen
bleiben und da habe ich mir kommen und
sich der franken melden weil sie nicht
krank werden wollen man hat ja
angehörige zu hause
die mitarbeiter haben kinder zu hause
man hat viele männer zu hause
und die stellt man in folge haben die
und mitzukriegen mal wirklich live mit
zu kriegen dass die angst vor allem
haben
die zweite welle im dezember traf die
altenheime schwer
rund die hälfte der 50 tausend
todesopfer zwischen november und januar
kam aus den heimen 89 prozent aller
corona toten seit beginn der pandemie
waren über 70 jahre alt aber es starben
auch 230 pflegekräfte der pfleger ist
überzeugt wäre in dem heim im dezember
wie geplant weiter geimpft worden wäre
die katastrophe dort zu stoppen gewesen
[Musik]
die schreckensbilanz 120 infizierte
heimbewohner 60 infizierte mitarbeiter
und mitarbeiterinnen 28 tote hätte man
diese todesfälle in der 2 corona welle
nach den erfahrungen aus dem frühjahr
verhindern können
[Musik]
professor heinz rothgang von der
universität bremen hat bereits im mai
2020 untersucht welche maßnahmen die
menschen in den altenheimen schützen
könnten und vorschläge für die regierung
ausgearbeitet
das hat mich etwas enttäuscht wie wir
als ganzes land im sommer reagiert haben
weil es war eigentlich absehbar dass die
zweite welle kommen würde und das ist
sinnvoll wer sich darauf vorzubereiten
wir haben reden häufig davon dass man
die einrichtung besonders schützen muss
aber auch da ist nichts passiert im
sinne von besuchs konzepten im sinne von
technischen lösungen von von
luftreiniger wir haben wenn wir ehrlich
sind im sommer gehofft es möge an uns
vorübergehen und ein bisschen die hände
im schoß zusammengelegt und das ist uns
dann im spätherbst und im winter ganz
schön auf die füße gefallen pflegeheim
bergneustadt 36 am morgen dienstbeginn
für andrea gaba
36 bewohnerinnen und bewohner warten auf
sie und fünf kolleginnen durch krone
welt immer wieder personal aus
gleichzeitig gehen da können sie mich
noch mal was erzählen aber noch da ein
bisschen zusammen reden den rücken
mit dieser mobile cremona die
morgendliche pflege ist besonders
zeitaufwendig doch es ist nicht viel
zeit
im nächsten zimmer wartet schon eine
andere pflegebedürftige mit
individuellen bedürfnissen andrea dabei
hilft einer bewohnerin nach der anderen
aus dem bett wäscht sie und macht sie
für das frühstück fertig heute ist die
36 jährige für einige schon zu spät dran
[Musik]
wieder ohne schuhe
das hat dann alles ein bisschen stressig
man muss halt dann ruhe bewahren neues
bringt der nächste mal nicht selber
durcheinander und gestresst ist muss man
ja sonst trifft man die bewohner auch
noch und das bringt nichts da werden die
auch nur durcheinander und nervös
deswegen muss man als mit ruhm machen
da muss man halt die zeit hinten
dranhängen geht halt nicht anders immer
wieder überstunden in der pandemie hat
sich die situation weiter verschärft
heimleiter georg huber bespricht sich
mit der pflegedienstleiterin beide
versuchen trotz der angespannten
situation die belegschaft motiviert zu
halten
aus seiner sicht muss sich
grundsätzliches in der pflege ändern
es habe ich glaub wenn wir lernen aus
dem was vergangen ist wo menschen
gestorben sind haben wir die chance dazu
besser zu machen
wir müssen aufpassen dass wir die chance
nicht verspielen und nur testen und
impfen ist mit das wichtigste aber das
drumherum muss eben auch stimmen im
januar brachte gesundheitsminister jens
spahn ein neues gesetz auf den weg das
bis 2025 20.000 neue stellen in der
pflege vorsieht doch für viele
pflegekräfte ist das zu spät und zu
wenig was stört die betroffenen selbst
am meisten
wir treffen den altenpfleger und
aktivist und stefan heyde von der aktion
pflegekräfte in mainz demonstrieren
heute 55 pflegerinnen und pfleger
jeweils stellvertretend für ihre
einrichtung und ihren bilden
wurden sie anfangs noch gefeiert und
beklatscht fühlen sich die pflegenden
jetzt von politik und gesellschaft im
stich gelassen
wir haben wirklich das ziel aus den
augen verloren dass wir sagen pflege ist
wertvoll und pflege betrifft jeden und
pflege muss auch dementsprechend bezahlt
und honoriert werden weil halt auch die
gesellschaft gesehen hat wie die pflege
blutet und wie sie leidet überall und
die gesellschaft hat sie nicht geschafft
haben sich dementsprechend für die
pflege stark zu machen
die tarifverhandlungen für eine bessere
und vor allem einheitliche bezahlen in
der pflege sind vor einigen wochen
gescheitert
kommerzielle einrichtungen haben damit
weiterhin keine tarifbindung
altenpfleger stefan halte kämpft seit
sechs jahren an vorderster front doch
viel verändert hat sich nicht auch die
korona krise hat den pflegenden in
krankenhäusern und altenheimen
letztendlich nicht mehr anerkennung
gebracht
seit beginn der pandemie haben 9.000
pflegekräfte ihren job aufgegeben
in den fünfzehn 1380 pflegeheimen gibt
es rund 765.000 mitarbeitende
9,5 millionen überstunden gab es in der
pflege schon 2016 2020 werden es um
einiges mehr gewesen sein
der pflegeberuf ist derzeit nicht
attraktiv ein problem für alle sagt
stefan heyde die problematik im
gesundheitssystem wird eines der
hauptthemen sein des 21 jahrhunderts
leben natürlich dem klima wir brauchen
auch eine vernünftige ausbildung für
personal und wir brauchen gute
arbeitsbedingungen weil ansonsten ist
keiner mehr da der die nächsten
generationen einfach pflegt den
generationen die immer älter und kränker
wird und deshalb habe ich auch angst
dass vielleicht für meine generation da
keine pflegekräfte haben wir da sind die
einen dementsprechend auffliegen können
vieles liegt im argen in der pflege
die pandemie brachte zusätzliche schwere
belastungen für bewohner und
pflegekräfte viele einrichtungen haben
sämtliche besucher über monate verboten
die pflegebedürftigen waren lange zeit
in ihren zimmern isoliert menschlich oft
eine unerträgliche situation für die
bewohner und ihre angehörigen
auch peter eichelmann und seine frau
konnten ihre 94 jährige mutter zehn
wochen lang nicht besuchen und nicht mit
ihr spazieren gehen und wie sonst immer
wochenlang musste die 94 jährige noch
anfang des jahres auf ihrem zimmer
bleiben trotz impfung
das haben wir auch der heimleitung
klausur gesagt dass das unseren augen
einfach frites brauchen ist das ist eine
gesunde person gewesen
es waren keine infektion im gesamten
heim letztlich sie war gesund sie war
bei vollem bewusstsein ihrer ihrer
geistigen kräfte
sie wollte rausgehen sie wollte auch
nicht eingesperrt werden und sie durfte
nicht das ist freiheitsberaubung michael
mann suchte rat beim biwak pflege
schutzbund in bonn
die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter der
verbraucherschutzorganisation helfen die
keine lobby haben den pflegebedürftigen
und ihren angehörigen
sie war die ganze zeit ausschließlich
rechtsanwältin ulrike kempchen vertritt
die angehörigen wenn nötig auch vor
gericht doch nur selten kommt es zu
einer klage viele trauen sich nicht an
die öffentlichkeit berichten aber über
missstände
letztendlich kommt es natürlich wenn
menschen unter druck arbeiten auch zu
mängeln das kann man einfach nicht
verleugnen
haben sie auch so eine art von
verwahrlosung oder so was sind schon
festgestellt gesprochen wurde über die
abnahme gewichtsabnahme über ungepflegte
zustände und über einbußen zum beispiel
in der mobilität aber auch in der
sprache in den kognitiven fähigkeiten
das ist das was uns angehörige
gespiegelt haben dann ist es aber so
dass sie als anwältin sollte man meinen
ja jetzt ganz viele klagen von
angehörigen haben die versuchen an die
öffentlichkeit zu gehen und sich zu
beschweren aber es ist ja eigentlich gar
nicht so war nicht dass das die
angehörigen auf diese missstände nicht
aufmerksam machen liegt überwiegend
daran dass man sich nicht traut etwas zu
sagen wenn ich einen pflegebedürftige
angehörige habe die versorgt werden muss
einer einrichtung dann bin ich darauf
angewiesen dass diese pflege erfolgt und
wenn ich abends nach hause gehe weiß ich
nicht ob es repressalien für mein
verhalten als angehöriger gibt diese
angst treibt schlichtweg die angehörigen
um so ging es auch peter eikelmann
am ende verzichtete er auf eine klage
inzwischen kann er seine schwiegermutter
wieder besuchen
doch in den pflegeheimen bleibt die
betreuungssituation angespannt dort
braucht es nicht nur mehr sondern auch
zufriedene pflegekräfte um krisen zu
bewältigen
ich meine wir haben ja auch diese krone
hilfe dieses corinna geld erhalten das
war natürlich sehr schön klar ist alles
was mehr ist es immer super aber im
endeffekt ist es ja ein tropfen auf dem
heißen stein weil es ist einmalig und
das war's damit ist er uns nicht
geholfen in der pflege wir brauchen
einfach mehr personal und man müsste das
halt attraktiver gestalten für die
neulinge für die auszubildenden ihr
müsst einfach mehr das ins licht rücken
und sagen das ist nicht nur pflege das
ist halt so vieles dazu gehört dass man
für die menschen da ist dass die
menschen auch für einen selber da sind
das wie gesagt dieses geben und nehmen
ist so wichtig das war ja vorher dass
der korb so hoch war jetzt ist er ja
super
[Musik]
noch ist man hier von normalität weit
entfernt kurz vor unserem dreh hat sich
ein pfleger des anderen heims bei seiner
tochter mit dem corona virus angesteckt
und fiel aus jetzt ist das haus wieder
geschlossen obwohl alle bewohner geimpft
sind
also wenn klar ist dass wir 100 bis 140
1000 stellen dass die fehlen dann war
das vorher klar und dann ist das auch
nach corona klar dass dann ist das 2021
klaren dann ist das 2022 klar
uns drängt die zeit wir sind eindruck
und wir brauchen unterstützung
über jahre wurde die pflege
vernachlässigt und in der pandemie wurde
viel zu spät gehandelt
diese versäumnisse sind seit beginn der
korona krise eskaliert mit fatalen
folgen
dringend muss sich etwas ändern denn
pflege brauchen wir alle irgendwann
[Musik]